hi everyone i know it's two days late i  just wanted to wish all of you a happy  new year  this has been quite an amazing year for  this channel i think i started out with  about  200 subscribers at the beginning of the  year now we're up to almost 60  000 and of course that's all thanks to  you so thank you all so much for the  support to this year for  watching the videos for subscribing for  telling your friends about the videos  and uh just for creating a great  community for discussion about religion  this is really exactly what i wanted  when i started this channel so  thank you all so much and i hope the  coming year will be  at least somewhat better than the one  that came before and because god knows  we all  had a pretty hard time this year so  thank you all so much i'll see you in  the next video